Salzburg hat viel Schönes zu bieten
– Berge, einen barocken Stadtkern,
eine stolze, mittelalterliche Festung;
dazu eine der bekanntesten Einkaufsstraßen
Österreichs, die Getreidegasse.
Touristenführerin Inez gibt euch ein paar
Tipps, wo sich die Salzburger gern aufhalten
– zum Beispiel im Café Classic.
Das ist jetzt mein Favorit:
der Kakao hier.
In Mozarts Wohnhaus gibt‘s unten
das Café Classic
und das wissen viele gar nicht.
Das ist ein Platz, wo die Salzburger
ganz gern hingehen – ich auch.
In der ersten Etage des Wohnhauses
stehen die musealen Kostbarkeiten.
Die Tasten anschlagen darf man
nur mit Sondererlaubnis.
Das ist jetzt das alte Hammerklavier
der Familie Mozart.
Wolfgang hat selber auch drauf gespielt.
Die Steingasse:
Sie ist Touristen weitgehend unbekannt,
dabei gehört sie zum
ältesten Teil Salzburgs.
Die ersten Häuser entstanden hier
bereits im 11. Jahrhundert.
Diese markante Einkerbung ist
jedoch wesentlich jünger.
Das ist nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg entstanden,
als die Amerikaner hier in Salzburg waren.
Und die GIs, die jungen Soldaten,
haben versucht,
in diese Gasse mit so 'ner Art Klein-Panzer,
Kleinlaster reinzufahren,
weil da hinten waren interessante Damen.
Und sie hatten leider schon ein
paar Bierchen getrunken
und sind dann festgefahren natürlich
und man hat sie nach hinten
wieder rausziehen müssen.
Und die Salzburger haben das
so witzig gefunden,
dass sie das, diese Spur, einfach
gelassen haben.
Die Salzburger erfreuen sich
nicht nur an ihrer Geschichte:
Zunächst als Bauwerk umstritten,
zieht das Museum der Moderne seit
2004 jährlich tausende Besucher an.
Erstens ist die Lage natürlich
fantastisch hier oben.
Man schaut über die Stadt und dann
ist es wahnsinnig wichtig für mein Gefühl,
dass wir außer dieses Barocke,
Alte, Traditionelle
auch neue Dinge haben und das
Museum ist natürlich genau der Platz dafür.
Im Restaurant "M32" im
Museumsgebäude
könnt ihr dann den Tag in Salzburg
entspannt ausklingen lassen.